alors dites-nous yannick jadot vous avez
eu des mots très forts il ya quelques
jours vous vouliez porté plainte contre
la commission européenne
nous avons engagé ce bras de fer avec la
commission européenne pour dire nous
voulons les citoyens européens méritent
la transparence sur ces contrats donc on
est dans ce dans le processus d' échange
de l'aide parce que c'est un processus
très encadré d échange de lettres avec
la commission pour bien garantir que la
commission ne veut pas être transparents
et effectivement nous irons devant la
cour de justice européenne pour imposer
la commission son devoir de transparence
sur la question des quelques états qui
aujourd'hui s'adressent à d'autres
fournisseurs d'autres laboratoires
que ce soit les laboratoires où il ya
déjà des autorisations mais aussi
évidemment les vaccins russes et les
vaccins chinois
moi là je crois que la seule réponse à
ça c'est à la fois aujourd'hui pour
l'union européenne de d'imposer ce qu'on
appelle la licence obligatoire c'est à
dire qu'en fait c'est dans le droit
français dans le droit européen dans le
droit international
on récupère les brevets on compense les
laboratoires mais on récupère les
brevets pour massifier la production en
situation de crise sociale de crise
économique de crise sanitaire évidemment
de détresse psychologique mayer majeur
dans l'ensemble du monde on se laisse
ballotter par l'agenda des laboratoires
qui veulent évidemment récompenser leurs
recherches mais franchement l'europe va
dépenser probablement 20 milliards
d'euros ou plus dans la vaccination
pareil pour les états unis
est-ce qu'on peut pas aujourd'hui mettre
les équipes de pfizer de moderna
d'astrazeneca et d'autres autour de la
table pour nous faire les meilleurs
vaccins
les vaccins qui y compris répondront aux
variants qui sont déjà là ou qui vont
arriver et qu'on dise on met le paquet
sur les capacités production pour
massifier la la vaccination chez nous et
dans le reste du monde parce que si on
vaccine pas le reste du monde
ce qu'on fera chez nous pour être
totalement percuté par de nouveaux
variants avis et on se laisse vite
emballé pas tout le monde en tout cas un
certain mario draghi qui vient à peine
d'arriver à la tête de l'italie bloque
désormais l'exportation des vaccins
astrazeneca vers l'australie avec
d'ailleurs la bénédiction de la
commission européenne qui a demandé de
le faire
et est-ce que c'est comme ça qu'on va
gagner notre bras de fer avec les labos
il faut arrêter je les dis on se fait
ballotter manipulés par les laboratoires
et notamment astrazeneca qui nous avait
promis beaucoup de doses on a beaucoup
investi sur astrazeneca c'est 350
millions d'euros pour leur permettre de
produire et on sait que astrazeneca a
très largement favorisé la grande
bretagne
ça lui permet de vacciner beaucoup plus
a réduit la fourniture de doses à
l'union européenne malgré les
engagements et potentiellement
exporterait sur d'autres pays
donc la question et pas de se replier
sur nous-mêmes de vouloir nous vacciner
tout seul au détriment du reste du monde
mais c'est d'avoir un rapport de force
équilibrés avec les labos astrazeneca a
promis des doses
on a payé astrazeneca ne peut pas
délocaliser j'avais dire une partie des
doses qui nous sont promises
[Musique]